et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
fabien roussel bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du nord
et secrétaire national du parti
communiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentait ce matin par
sébastien corps atteindre jean-sébastien
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
aux journalistes à l'écho républicain
vous représentez le groupe centre france
on va commencer par la crise sanitaire
et ce projet de loi fabien roussel qui
est examiné ce matin au conseil des
ministres et qui prolonge de six mois à
la possibilité de prendre des mesures
restrictives pour faire face à cette
crise sanitaire
le gouvernement pourra notamment limiter
les déplacements limités les
rassemblements en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie finalement
c'est une sorte de prolongement inde
état d'urgence sanitaire même si ça ne
porte pas son nom est ce que ce sont des
mesures que vous allez voter c'est un
texte que vous allez à prouver quand le
parlement sera amené à se prononcer
dessus
nous allons surtout nous battre pour que
l'on mette plus de moyens dans les
mesures à mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui
face à cette pandémie et je regrette que
le discours du premier ministre
il ya quelques jours quand il a fait des
annonces face à la recrudescence de la
pandémie ait eu un discours creux nous
vague sans mesure précise
or aujourd'hui ce que le gouvernement
nous propose c'est des mesures de
limitation de circulation des mesures
répressives
alors que nous commençons à rentrer dans
une période de tension dans les hôpitaux
avec des services de réanimation qui
accueille des malades qui ne sont pas
qu'ils ont pas là l'aco vide mais qui
doivent être soignés et donc les soins
ont repris dans les hôpitaux depuis la
fin du confinement et à cela s'ajoutent
des patients qui ont la coved et donc on
a des hôpitaux qui sont de nouveau en
tension on a un problème de test vous
l'avez vu avec faut attendre parfois
cinq jours six jours pour avoir ses
résultats après avoir fait la queue
pendant cinq à six heures c'est quand
même incroyable
il faut il oser france ben oui il faut
développer une politique de test mais ça
manque de réactifs de principe réactif
ça manque de machines ça manque de bras
que fait le gouvernement
ils nous disent fait des tests mais la
tendance ne suis pas content à revenir
sur ce projet de loi présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres sera examiné à
l'assemblée à partir du 1er octobre
c'est oui ou c'est les jeux
vous direz que ben non il arrive donc
d'abord on va le découvrir c'est un
réchauffement et jeu s'est désisté déjà
dit déjà que nous allons nous battre
pour y mettre du contenu des moyens pour
nos hôpitaux de l'argent pour l'hopital
pas pour le capital ça c'est notre
slogan notre affiche et c'est ce que
l'on répétera il faut des moyens humains
dans nos hôpitaux pour pouvoir faire
face et aux soins courants et à la
pandémie qui arrive et puis nous voulons
avoir des moyens pour avoir une
politique de test à la hauteur je pense
aussi à des mesures telles que la
journée de carence que l'on a rétabli
parce qu'on sortait de la période de
d'état d'urgence
sauf qu'aujourd'hui quand il ya des
personnes qui se trouvent mal à nous
empêcher de reprendre le travail et
c'est cette journée de carence
elle pénalise beaucoup de salariés et
donc par exemple ça nous allons demander
est ce que cette journée de carence se
soit retiré de nouveau voilà donc nous
voulons améliorer fortement un tel texte
quand on leur a découvert m'enfin je
sais qu'il va être creux comme le
discours du premier ministre est
justement dernier mot sur ce sujet vous
parlez de discours creux vous attendiez
des mesures plus sévères de la part de
jean castex
non mais c'est pas de la sévérité que
l'on cherche c'est de l'efficacité et
l'efficacité de faire des mesures telles
que vient la leaf a gagné quand des
familles sont quand dans une famille
d'une personne est testée positive
quelles conditions sont créées pour que
ces personnes ne retourne pas dans leur
foyer nous nous attendons d'avoir des
logements des hôtels débloquer je sais
que ça se fait à paris mais moi dans ma
région des hauts de france on a aucune
indication sais pas comment que ça
marche
enfin et de le premier ministre peut pas
dire les préfets vont gérer non c'est
pas possible ça peut pas se régler comme
ça et puis on laisse le soin aux agences
régionales de santé au rectorat qui sont
devenus des des états dans l'état le
soin de prendre des décisions parfois
avec des injonctions contradictoires
on sent bien qu'on a un état qui s'est
délitée des services publics qui ont
reculé du coup premier ministre qui dit
voile à gérer parce que nous on sait
plus faire c'est ça en gros 1
donc nous ce que l'on voudrait c'est
qu'il y à un état qui reprennent la main
qui donne des moyens
qui dirige insuffle etc puis tu vois là
un les sept juges sanitaire qui entraîne
une crise sociale économique on en parle
avec vous c'est mais voilà justement
cette crise sanitaire risque d'entraîner
une casse sociale massive comment
empêcher des suppressions d'emplois une
explosion du chômage
alors d'abord l'analyse que nous faisons
au parti communiste français c'est que
la crise économique était là avant la
crise sanitaire et aujourd'hui nous
subissons une double crise sanitaire et
économique parce que la loi du profit de
la rentabilité à tout crin avait déjà
comment dire ni des plans de
licenciement dans la seringue comme on
dit et aujourd'hui ses plans de
licenciements un bain la pandémie elle
tombe bien pour certaines grandes
multinationales parce que c'est
l'occasion de les mettre en oeuvre
donc ce que nous demandons nous c'est
que l'argent public est mis sur la table
et c'est pas une paille 460 milliards
d'euros de plans de soutien 100
milliards d'euros de plans de relance
vous pouvez chercher dans vos tablettes
il y a aucun précédent dans l'histoire
de notre pays autant d'argent public mis
sur la table cet argent c'est notre
argent
c'est l'argent des crues des
contribuables et donc nous voulons en
avoir le contrôle
et nous disons que cet argent doit
servir à maintenir les emplois et en
créer les deux maintenir les emplois et
à ancrer pas un centime
pas un euro d'argent public ne doit
servir à financer des plans de
licenciement or c'est tout l'inversé de
ce qui se passe en ce moment
alors justement sur ce plan de relance
vous avez déclaré que vous vouliez qu'il
soit réellement affecté aux besoins
humains à l'écologie qu'est ce que vous
lui reprochez à ce plan de relance qui
flèche quand même 30 milliards vers
l'écologie 36 vers les solidarités ça
fait quand même deux tiers de l'envelope
à quoi dans un quoi va servir cet argent
concrètement ou qui va en être
destinataire parce que quand on donne 5
milliards d'euros à renault sous forme
de subventions et de prêts mais de
subventions et que renault derrière se
désengage par exemple des fonderies du
poitou qui produit des carter en alu et
en fonte pour renault qui est le
principal client et que ça pourrait se
traduire par 300 à 500 suppressions
d'emplois eh bien je dis faute voilà
quand on met 5 milliards d'euros
d'argent public pour renault on rentre
dans le capital de renault
augmente sa participation et puis on
dirige et on dit renault va relocaliser
son industrie va ouvrir des sites va et
maintenir les emplois dans la production
automobile mais en plus ancrée c'est ça
que je dis un état stratège un état qui
planifie un état qui se bat pour sa
souveraineté économique et son industrie
et bien c'est un état qui agit donc
quand l'état vient avec autant d'argent
public et encore une fois de notre
argent
c'est pour rentrer dans le capital de
ces grands groupes et faire en sorte que
cet argent soit utile productif qu ils
permettent de maintenir les emplois et
d'en créer de nouveaux qu'est ce que
vous attendez comme contrepartie pour
les ménages justement j'attends pour les
ménages que le pouvoir d'achat ne
fondent pas comme neige au soleil
le chômage partiel c'est bien quand on
arrive à à socialiser le chômage et
faire en sorte que des salariés ne
soient pas sortis de l'entreprise ça
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mais en
même temps pour tous ceux qui se sont
retrouvés en chômage partiel et qui
gagne légèrement au-dessus du smic c'est
16 % de salaire en moins ensuite il ya
un taux de pauvreté qui est en train
d'exploser dans notre pays j'entends
dire de la part des associations
humanitaires et caritatives que l'on
s'en va vers 12 à 13 millions de
personnes vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté on était à 9 millions avant la
crise et donc il ya un réel problème de
ce côté là comment on fait pour aider
ses retraités
ces salariés qui ont qui perdent du
salaire ou ses salariés qui tentent de
joindre les deux bouts avec 1200 euros
de salaire net vous rendez compte
comment on vit aujourd'hui avec 1200
euros de salaire net
j'entends parler d'ailleurs que
maintenant il faudrait augmenter la csg
que c'était la fin non non non il faut
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
aux salariés d'abord aux retraités
ensuite et garantir un revenu pour les
étudiants au lieu de leur promettre un
cdd de 3 mois
voilà des propositions concrètes que
nous mettons sur la table et c'est ici
que le plan de relance de resservir
juste parce que vous parlez de cette
augmentation de la csg que le
gouvernement a dit pas d'augmentation
d'impôts mais que dans le rapport qui
lui a été remis pour financer la
dépendance l'une des pistes c'est
l'augmentation de la csg pour les
retraités vous y opposez à mais
carrément non mais ça va mais si vous
voulez remettre le feu dans le pays
parler de la hausse de la csg se re
sur le dos des retraités ou des salariés
enfin on va payer jusque quand fans nous
on paye je pense que les français les
consignes aux concitoyens les salariés
comme les retraités n'ont pas le
sentiment de ne rien faire ne pas
contribuer au pays et à notre modèle
social
nous payons par nos cotisations par la
tva par nos impôts nous ne payons quand
est ce qu'on va se mettre à faire payer
les multinationales les google les
amazones les gaffes a comme on dit les
grandes fortunes de notre pays il est
lvmh les bernard arnault les mulliez les
bettencourt et compagnie ils ont le
patrimoine des 500 plus grandes fortunes
totalisent un montant de 730 milliards
d'euros de patrimoine
il a encore augmenté par rapport à
l'année dernière quand est ce que vont
contribuer je parle pas que de l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune
j'ai envie une période de tel
aujourd'hui que l'on aurait pu mettre en
place un impôt kovy d'une taxe coville
donc que les gros pays gros et que les
petits paye petit enfin c'était une
revendication d'ailleurs porté par les
gérer jeunes que j'ai reprise mais qu'il
y est injuste impôts payés par tous
nous nous le payons à eux de payer de
mettre leurs contributions sur la table
et ensuite quand l'état met 560
milliards d'euros d'argent public sur la
table pour sortir de la crise que mais
le capital sur la table qu'est ce qu'ils
mettent eux pour relocaliser pour nos
services publics pour sauver l'industrie
qu'est ce qu'ils mettent sur la table
euh non seulement ils demandent de
l'argent public
mais les grandes boîtes mais en plus ils
licencient derrière c'est inadmissible
inadmissible
donc nous demandons à ce que le capital
aussi apporte sa contribution au
redressement du pays
alors justement parlez de vos
contre-proposition avec vous célestin
voilà vous avez mis sur la table un
certain nombre de contre propositions
qui sont rassemblés sur une plateforme
participative 1 la france en commun vous
lister quinze chantiers prioritaires
emploi logement réindustrialisation
amélioration de la protection sociale
transition écologique
à combien chiffrez vous ce plan de
relance et comment voulu finances riez
alors il y a dix sept thématiques
effectivement 17 propositions sur
différents sujets que nous
rendons accessible via une plateforme
numérique mais nous allons aussi
organiser des débats décentralisés dans
les départements les régions pour parler
avec les gens ce que nous voulons c'est
construire avec les citoyens c'est une
démarche citoyenne collaborative et nous
faisons une série de propositions pour
l'environnement par le pouvoir d'achat
pour l'emploi qui sont nos priorités
emploi pouvoir d'achat climat même
combat et donc c'est la priorité pour le
pays
nous faisons une série de propositions
dedans donnant en termes de fiscalité et
une fiscalité plus juste
c'est à dire comme je le disais
précédemment de faire en sorte que
l'argent du capital servent à produire
s'agit pas seulement de le taxer mais
qu'il serve à relocaliser des
productions
à respecter l'être humain et
l'environnement dans la manière de
produire les besoins dont notre dont
nous avons besoin et donc pour sortir de
ce modèle sais c'est pas qu'une question
d'argent c'est ce que je veux dire c'est
que pour sortir de ce modèle il faut que
l'on arrive à produire autrement
consommer autrement mais produire
autrement ça se fera pas comme ça d'un
claquement de doigts donc il va falloir
faire avec faire avec les acteurs
économiques donc faire avec ce qu'est
faire avec les actionnaires pour cela il
faudra donc les contraindre c'est ce que
nous proposons par la modulation des
cotisations par exemple pour faire en
sorte que ces grandes entreprises ait
bien réduisent le temps de travail
permettent de partir plus tôt à la
retraite pour que des jeunes puissent
arriver sur dans l'emploi investir dans
la formation
surtout en période de pandémie c'est
maintenant investissons amenant donc
vous voyez nous faisons des propositions
de ce type ce n'est pas qu'une question
d'argent
je changer de modèle produire autrement
ce n'est pas qu'une question d'argent
alors là c'est un autre sujet fabien
roussel va parler de la 5g il se débat
qui monte d'abord je voudrais réagir à
cette phrase d'emmanuel mâcon qui a fait
beaucoup parler j'entends beaucoup de
voix qui s'élèvent pour nous expliquer
qu'il faudrait relever la complexité des
problèmes contemporains en revenant à la
lampe à huile
je ne crois pas que le modèle amish
permettent de régler les défis de
l'écologie contemporaine qu'avez vous
pensé de cette phrase quand j'ai entendu
cette phrase les rend plus quand j'ai vu
les images de ce président de la
république qui arrive tout bronzé col
ouvert
comme s'il sortait de son hélicoptère
août sa cabine à uv personnel
pour nous faire la leçon et traiter ceux
qui demandent un débat sur la 5g damisch
je me dis c'est pas un président de la
république que je vois là c'est le
président d'un conseil d'administration
d'une start up qui parlent assez à ses
actionnaires enfin les citoyens français
ils sont pas les actionnaires d'une
start up on a le droit à un débat en
plus le comité citoyen pour le climat
avait demandé un moratoire sur 7,5 g et
lui il s'assoit dessus mais en plus ils
nous insultent mais c'est inadmissible
et se prend pour qui c'est une insulte à
mais c'est car elle c'est du mépris et
ses deux reins sulky compris ceux qui
sans quel que soit le débat pour ou
contre
et d'ailleurs je suis moi pour un débat
et qu'on aille au bout et qu'on attende
que les études concernant les risques
sanitaires environnementaux soient
publiés il y en a une qui sera public au
mois de mars
c'est la raison pour laquelle on attend
que ces études arrivent tous les âges
vous êtes et un moratoire pour l'instant
oui et je suis pour ne pas hystériser le
débat je ne alors moi je fais partie
le parti communiste ne faisons partie de
ceux qui disent que la 5g ce ne sera pas
la solution de tous nos problèmes et en
même temps la 5g et c'est pas
l'apocalypse non plus en revanche ce que
nous disons c'est que avoir une maîtrise
publique d'une telle technologie pour la
mettre au service du développement
humain et pas pour la mettre au service
de grandes multinationales
encore une fois ça c'est un enjeu d'en
avoir la maîtrise publique je pense
notamment aux salariés de nokia alcatel
qui devait à qui on avait promis d'être
ceux qui seraient en pointe sur
l'installation et la recherche sur la 5g
aujourd'hui ça licencie chez nokia donc
y compris cette technologie à se re
service de qui demain
de quel pays argent lui j'entends bien
que surtout pas les chinois mais qu'ils
les américains alors donc on va se
vendre aux américains c'est ça le sujet
mais je préfère moi parler du progrès
que représente cette technologie mais
comment on fait pour la contrôler la
maîtriser et que effectivement si elle
apporte des bienfaits dans la médecine
ou et bien que ce soit cantonné à cela
et non pas à les gaver
de nouvelles de nouveaux gafa autre
temps que vous n'y êtes pas forcément
posée mais pour un débat et pour un
moratoire on va parler de la gauche et
olivier faure le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste qui propose un
printemps de la gauche et de l'écologie
avec celles et ceux qui le voudront est
ce que vous faites partie de ceux qu'ils
veulent pas écouter ce qui est important
c'est que on arrive ensemble a montré
que nous pouvons sortir de ce modèle
économique et d'en bâtir un autre un
nouveau modèle économique social
écologique citoyens solidaires nous
communistes nous y croyons nous sommes
ceux qui demandent ont justement à
rompre avec le modèle actuel qui broie
l'être humain où on a senti le sentiment
nous d'être des pions pas respectés pas
écouter juste utile pour travailler
point barre donc sortir de ce modèle
alors participé à un échange construire
ensemble une plate-forme des
propositions oui et je redis ici ça ne
doit pas se faire entre chefs de partis
ça doit se construire avec les citoyens
c'est ça le le printemps marseillais
c'est pas un accord entre responsables
politiques de marseille
c'est avec les citoyens avec des
associations avec des responsables
syndicaux avec ceux qui portent des
propositions pour le climat pour
l'emploi pour la culture pour pour le
c'est ça qu'il faut faire
donc c'est construire avec les ans il ya
eu un programme commun de mitterrand et
marcher moi je suis pour le programme en
commun que nous devons faire avec les
gens et qu'ils en aient la maîtrise aux
régionales et aux eaux départementale
est ce que ça peut passer par des
alliances avec
le ps allié historique ou avec la france
insoumise nous discutons tous ensemble
nous discutons avec l'ensemble des
forces politiques le parti qui
l'ensemble des politiques communistes
discute en ce moment avec la france
insoumise avec le parti socialiste avec
les verts et nous entretenons aussi un
dialogue qui est pour nous indispensable
avec les organisations syndicales avec
des associations avec qui nous voulons
aussi construire le programme qui va
répondre aux besoins de notre pays et de
nos habitants nous vous la citoyenneté
quand on veut une démarche citoyenne
c'est ça c'est pas un accord au sommet
c'est de la base au sommet que l'on doit
construire le parti communiste vous
savez il a vécu le programme commun
alors certes il a permis de faire gagner
la gauche
mais c'est vite retombé derrière parce
que le parti socialiste il est devenu
hégémonique sans contrôle citoyen et
ensuite il est tombé dans des dérives
libérales que nous ne voulons plus
jamais revoir donc il faut que le peuple
les français s'emparent de de ce que
nous voulons faire donc de ce programme
de ce chantier de ce que nous voulons
mettre ensemble en oeuvre pour semer
clairement votre travail aboutira à des
listes communes de la gauche aux
régionales plus nous arrivons à
construire des listes ensemble et avec
des citoyens mieux ce sera ça ne doit
pas être des listes de formation
politique ça doit être aux élections
régionales et départementales et
départementales des listes que nous
construirons ensemble et avec des hommes
et des femmes engagés dans leur région
sur des sujets sur lesquels ils sont
forts l'environnement la culture
l'emploi l'industrie imaginez que vous
nommez dans ma région des hauts de
france
un vice-président développement
économique qui est un responsable
syndical
spécialiste des questions industrielles
je peux vous dire qu'il va surveiller
chacune des usines de ma région comme le
lait sur le feu et que on va se donner
les moyens de préserver notre tissu
industriel justement puisque vous parlez
de votre région des hautes france vous
serez candidat aux régionales dans cette
région
on en discute je suis j'étais candidat
en
1015 et avec d'autres de mes camarades
nous avons d'ailleurs publié une tribune
dans le journal liberté blood ma région
dans lequel nous formulons notre
disponibilité et ma disponibilité pour
conduire une liste de rassemblement des
forces de gauche et citoyenne dans cette
région dont clairement vous souhaitez
mener la liste des autres ans un espoir
dans cette région de pouvoir passer le
cap d'une région véritablement citoyenne
qui s'attaque aux problèmes
environnementaux parce qu'on a eu un
président de région qu'a clairement fait
le choix de ne pas se préoccuper des
questions environnementales et
climatiques et c'est un grand problème
parce qu'on a pris beaucoup de retard
dans ce domaine et qui mettra donc au
coeur de son combat l'emploi voilà
l'emploi le pouvoir d'achat le climat à
ce que je disais nationalement c'est
valable
régionalement donc clairement vous êtes
candidat pour être tête de liste
régionale angelis disponible pour
construire ce rassemblement mais mauvais
oeil par les avec le parti socialiste
à vous de mener cette liste bien sûr ils
sont d'accord bien sûr nous en parlons
ils sont d'accord mais nous en parle
forcément d'accord pour le voir en un
mot sur l'élection qui aura lieu après
les régionales la présidentielle oui
voix le parti communiste est absent de
la présidentielle depuis 2007 et marie
george buffet ce que vous souhaitez qui
est un candidat communiste en 2022 ce
que j'aimerais c'est que il y ait un
changement de cap important dans notre
pays et que les français se sont enfin
écouté respecté
dans leur dignité ce que je souhaite
c'est que les immenses richesses de
notre pays soient mises au service de
l'être humain et de la planète et donc
sa demande de sortir de ce modèle
économique de sortir du capitalisme donc
il faut bâtir un autre modèle mais sur
l'incarnation s'appelle la partie à une
idée phare le parti communiste français
portent un tel projet l'élection
présidentielle est l'occasion d'avoir un
débat avec nos concitoyens sur la france
dans laquelle ils souhaitent vivre et
donc nous voulons nous à cette occasion
apporté donc des propositions montrer
que c'est possible
donc aujourd'hui on est à deux ans de
l'élection présidentielle vous dire où
on en sera six mois ou un an avant je ne
peux pas vous le dire nous on met le
candidat unique vous n'y êtes pas posé
sur l'idée je suis je suis je
je voudrais m'arrêter là sur les
élections présidentielles parce que la
priorité aujourd'hui des français c'est
pas l'élection présidentielle c'est pas
sa gêne vous dire que nous notre souhait
c'est de sortir de ce modèle et que
économique et que nous faisons des
propositions pour cela mais la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est ceux qui sont menacés
de licenciement c'est ce qu'ils perdent
du pouvoir d'achat et donc notre combat
c'est celui là c'est pour ça que nous
appelons nous a manifesté devant les
préfectures le 10 octobre prochain pour
demander à chaque préfet pour demander à
l'état des comptes sur l'argent public
qui coule à flots en ce moment et nous
nous demandons que dans chaque
département dans chaque région cet
argent public serve à nos hôpitaux à
notre industrie à l'environnement et
donc dans chaque départements le 10
octobre prochain nous nous battrons
c'est ça notre priorité c'est pas
l'élection présidentielle dernière
question qui n'est pas sur l'élection
présidentielle à sébastien alors oui
députés lrm de chartres guillaume casbah
riant va déposer aujourd'hui un
amendement anti squatters dans le cadre
du projet de loi de simplification de
l'action publique c'est un amendement
qui est soutenu par la ministre déléguée
au logement et qui fait suite le haut
fait divers une affaire de squat à
théoule sur mer qui est intervenue en
début d'un début de mois dans une
résidence secondaire alors que cet
amendement qu'est ce qu'ils proposent de
clarifier la notion de domicile et 2
de faciliter et d'accélérer les mesures
et les procédures d'expulsion justement
pour ces résidences secondaires est-ce
que vous soutenez un tel amendement
je soutiens une telle démarche parce que
ce qui est arrivé dans ce village à
cette famille est inadmissible
donc je partage c'est ça suscite une
colère tout à fait légitime et il y à
d'autres propositions à mettre en oeuvre
notamment la réquisition de logements
vacants camp des propriétaires ne
veulent pas mettre en location leur
logement et qu'ils restent vides pendant
des années des années alors qu'il ya
tant de personnes qui cherchent des
logements
je trouve cela aussi parfaitement
injuste et donc je pense aussi à toutes
celles et ceux qui cherchent des
logements et qui sagement dans le
respect des règles de la république
attendent d'être relogées et qui vivent
parfois dans des logements insalubres
donc il faut tenir les deux bouts pour
être juste donc oui pour que ceux qui
sont propriétaires soient respectés dans
leurs droits
mais oui pour avoir une véritable
politique de logement digne pour chacun
de nos concitoyens et ce sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup à celle